protesters described it as an enemy
invasion of every Jordanian home by
accepting natural gas from Israel to
generate electricity they say each time
they turn on their lights they'll be
giving the Israeli government money a
gas deal is like literally it's like
funding the Zionism project and in
Palestine which is like its funding is
really like government and like more
like you know violate the human rights
and like it killed Palestinian people
last month an israeli-american
consortium began pumping natural gas
from a pipeline in the Mediterranean Sea
to Jordan since the public first learned
about the deal in 2014 protesters
ranging from Palestinian refugees to
members of parliament have united in
opposition
even if we're poor we cannot exchange
our dignity and we can change our rights
with the wealth with with anyone and
this is what we wear we think we can
survive
Jordan relies on imports to meet its
energy needs it also survives on foreign
aid it's waiting for the IMF to inject a
loan into its economy the government
says this ten billion dollar 15 year
deal with Israel is the cheapest
cleanest and most reliable option it has
at the moment and it could decrease the
cost of electric bills which jordanian
say is too high Jawad inany is a former
Deputy Prime Minister he says until
Jordan can become energy independent the
Israeli pipeline offers the best
alternative it will be pumped as gas and
it will reach us as gas so there is no
need to liquefy it and we Gaza fight
again and that would have saved so much
on their cost as long as there's a need
peace with Jordan and think of Jordan
stability as a helpful to the Israeli
security they I doubt that they would
would would actually interrupt
the guests of light protesters remain
unconvinced and say they'll continue to
try to halt the deal but public opinion
may shift if Jordanians electricity
bills start getting cheaper Natacha a
guy named Al Jazeera I'm N